well this is absolutely incredible we're  on the outskirts of Kirsten now we've  been given a military escort last year  and as you can see people are absolutely  [Music]  and waving the Ukrainian flag  um we're literally just on the outskirts  very early in the morning  so they're putting their thumbs up for  Britain obviously  Ukrainian soldiers have captured the  city  she's talking about the airport which is  just down there but this is the main  road into the city itself it's pretty  early in the morning but people are up  they're very grateful to see something  that they didn't think they would see  for perhaps a long time if ever at all  but Russia annexed this territory as you  can see Ukrainian flag now flying and it  is under the control of Ukrainian  soldiers